[Music]
at first glance I knew we had a
beautiful sign here in the making it's
definitely a restorable piece
my name is Howie Cohen
and I run a sign company in Utica New
York called just neon sign company and
I've been doing this since 1993.
the techniques are the same the
equipment has gotten a lot better
there are more gauges there's more more
analytical
data that we can obtain when we fill the
signs but essentially the whole process
is entirely the same since the beginning
[Music]
this particular sign is a Hudson
automobile sign
Hudson was a very popular make in
automobiles back in the 40s and 50s
they're no longer made but these signs
still exist in our highly desirable
amongst the collectors
signs of this nature at auction could
bring upwards to twenty to thirty
thousand dollars
my only task here is to restore the neon
the dealer that had this sign brought
this sign to me in the condition that it
is in and I took it upon myself then to
restore the sign using the original
materials that were used back in the
1940s which is neon tubing
when a sign comes in the first thing I
do is I make paper patterns of the neon
letters to be made once the tracing
paper is attached to the sign a black
marker can be used to outline the
beginning and the end of each letter
the interesting thing about making neon
is we do everything in Reverse so the
pattern I make here has to be reversed
before I begin making any Neon
the most challenging part of making a
good pattern is making a good tracing
you have to make sure your pattern is
not going to move that your paper is not
going to move and it's got to stay that
way through the entire tracing
the holes where the glass housings are
located if they're off a little bit your
neon unit that you install might not fit
and that would mean that you have to do
the whole thing over again
once I have the pattern made I can
measure out how many feet of glass I'm
going to be using
the glass tubing that we use is
specifically made for the neon sign
industry it comes in various diameters
this particular one is 12 millimeter in
diameter if you use a tube that's too
large you lose some of the detail if you
use a tube too small in diameter it
would require lots of Transformers to
power it we use a carbide tip Circle
cutter and a Dremel tool
with those two tools you can make nice
smooth accurate cuts
with my fires on my glass at hand I'm
going to be shaping the glass
it takes many years and years and years
and miles of glass
before a glass Bender could be
comfortable with making letters
the type of glass we use is a relatively
soft glass the fires we use either the
long ribbon burner to make gentle arcs
and curves or the sharper cannon fire
which is used to make what we call
double back bends the glass will soften
and then you really have to apply a
little bit of air by wave your mouth
into the glass tubing which will then
keep it round
the hose that's in my mouth is called
the blow hose without the blow hose it'd
be very difficult to put the proper
amount of air into the glass as it's
softening if you don't do this it will
crimp and the gas and the electricity
will not flow properly
the biggest challenge of the glass
bending process is not to get burned not
to get cut not to burn and then cut
yourself or cut yourself and then burn
yourself
everything is a challenge there's so
many things that can go wrong in making
neon
once the glass is bent it goes to the
bombarding table
the machine you're seeing is a manifold
this meters the gas in to the tube and
evacuates the tube and that's where all
the oxygen water vapor impurities are
pumped out
the glass is also heated it's heated to
a very hot temperature upwards of 300
degrees C very hot once it's that hot
almost all the impurities are pumped out
of that tube then the gas is filled
once the gas is applied to the tube and
filled properly a high voltage can be
passed through that
the high voltage excites the gas and in
this case it's argon there's also a
little drop of mercury that's added
inside the tube to make the glass
fluoresce when it lights up the proper
color then you know you had no leaks and
you had no issues
every neon sign is composed of a tube
sealed at both ends
these ends are called electrodes it's a
metal to Glass seal which allows the
electricity to go inside the tube
once the tubing is done it's time now to
mount it on the sign
the sign is a porcelain sign it doesn't
need painting it's actually a glass
material that's put over the top of
Steel is actually the surface that was
put on back in 1940.
there are small tube supports and then
these little wires are just Twisted
tight that's all it takes to fasten in
the end to the side
what I have here is a light socket in
the industry it's called The Glass
housing
this is placed inside the sign the metal
ring is then fitted onto the threads and
tightened down
when the neon sets in there it just
makes physical contact with that spring
inside the sign there is a 15
000 volt transformer powered to 110
primary
that's a lot of voltage but the current
is very low it's only approximately 30
milliamps it won't kill you
but you'll know it's there
I installed the glass housings the tube
supports the wiring on the inside and
the Transformer including the power cord
and switch
there's nothing more that makes me
happier than to take a piece of history
and bring it back to the original
condition that it was maybe 70 years ago
this is the way the sign came out of the
factory and this is the way it's going
to be kept
I'm really happy with the way this thing
turned out the colors are right they're
nice and bright everything is uniform
this sign is going to be a beautiful
addition to the Museum of the car
collector this is a great example of a
double-sided Porcelain sign with the
theme of automobiles in this case the
famous Hudson foreign
[Music]